we're watching two Atlantic hurricanes
that could affect millions of Americans
Hurricane Jose is moving north towards
eastern Long Island and Cape Cod but
Hurricane Maria in the Caribbean is a
far greater threat maria is slamming the
caribbean as a powerful category 5 storm
it made landfall last night on the
island of Dominica with 160 mile per
hour winds Maria is targeting other
islands that did not get the full fury
of Hurricane herma those islands include
Saint Croix in the US Virgin Islands and
Puerto Rico the public safety chief in
Puerto Rico told people in the path of
the storm this you have to evacuate
otherwise you are going to die David
Beck knows in San Juan where Maria where
Maria's first impact is expected in the
next 24 hours David good morning Gail
good morning this is catastrophic in
every way those are the words of the
National Weather Service here in San
Juan as Maria barrels toward this US
territory last night it was Dominica a
category 5 storm that made landfall
there in the middle of the night the
prime minister in fact made several
urgent posts on Facebook saying his roof
had been ripped off his house was
flooding and communication was nearly
non-existent on the island and now this
morning there are reports of widespread
devastation as Maria made landfall you
could see the powerful impacts on the
islands of Guadeloupe which sits just
north of Dominica heavy rains and wind
gusts of over 150 miles per hour
pounded several small countries recently
devastated by hurricane streets on the
island of Martinique are already
flooding earlier on Monday we traveled
by helicopter to Saint Thomas one of the
US Virgin Islands from the air the scope
of what her m'dear is apparent debris
still litters the island and could turn
into dangerous projectiles when Maria's
hurricane-force winds move in Dana Neil
and her two-year-old son Tucker James
stuck around during but now she's
getting out going to New Jersey to meet
her sister but she plans to come right
back after Maria to help rebuild what's
left on the island of Saint John why
didn't you want to get out it's where we
live and we need to be there to help
people schools are now shelters on st.
Thomas for those unable or unwilling to
evacuate EMT Jacob Bradley says all
critically ill patients are being
airlifted out and people staying behind
are being warned you can expect no EMS
no fire and no police response from the
locals because we believe the road is
going to wash out and if it washes out
there's nothing we can do back on the
island of Puerto Rico people are getting
ready for a direct hit from Maria
emptying out hardware and grocery stores
and waiting in long lines to fill up gas
tanks there are 500 shelters here on the
island of Puerto Rico that can house
about a hundred and thirty three
thousand people if needed charlie last
night when this category 5 storm made
landfall in Dominica it was only the
second time a cat5 storm made landfall
in the same year the last time Burma two
weeks ago David Beck no in San Juan
thank you David